what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to talking thrones as you can see
by the title of this video I want to
talk about the new and mysterious george
RR martin interview that was just
recently posted on a spanish blog site
if you want to read the full interview i
will put the link down in the
description of this video
one of the people that conducted this
interview is named milah castillo rey
who is a graduate in journalism and
author of the page the crypts of
Winterfell you may want to go and read
this for yourself because it is very
interesting but it's also a very
controversial interview right now
because many people are claiming it to
be fake based on some of the answers
George gave during this interview if
you've ever watched or listened to
George give an interview then you should
know that he is the king of subtleties
and he rarely ever gives a definitive
answer on anything that can be seen as a
spoiler for his books but in this
interview it appears that George shed a
much brighter light on a few things that
fans have been wondering which is why
this blog post has been raising so many
red flags for fans personally I do not
know if this is real or not and as of
right now no one has been able to
confirm or deny it a few people who are
close to George aren't sure what to make
of this yet either
but I hope they can get him to respond
to this so we know for a fact whether
this is real or not
I would actually be very surprised if he
gave some of these answers but I want to
go over a few of them with you because I
want to know what all of you think about
this if this interview happens to be
fake then this has taken fan fiction to
a whole new level when I went to the
original site that took this interview I
started to read some of the comments
about this interview and at least one of
the people who conducted this interview
are responding to most of the comments
and they're standing their ground that
this is in fact real I want to read a
few of these questions and George's
responses so let me know what you think
about all of this but keep in mind I was
reading a translated version of this so
some things may have been lost in
translation but let's begin one of their
questions was will the Iron Throne end
in the same conditions in both versions
if you had planned not to destroy it and
see the king or queen at the end of the
story would it be the same as in the
series what they are basically asking is
if someone is sitting on the Iron Throne
at the end of the sear
will it be the same person sitting there
at the end of your books
George responded by saying it would be
the same without a doubt but that does
not mean there are not going to be
surprises that nobody has seen or will
see in the television version
what is the use of knowing the end if
the path has not been enjoyed it does
not matter who reigns in Westeros when
all have died but how and why that
character has achieved it I think that
is a very interesting answer George
would have gave and in my opinion that
is potentially one of the biggest
spoilers he could give now I could be
misinterpreting the question or answer
but it appears to me that if the show
would happen to end with Jonathan Aerys
on the throne then the books would end
in the exact same way
taking different paths of course but
knowing the end result from the show as
a massive spoiler for the books because
the show is gonna end years before a
dream of spring comes out which I assume
will reveal who is the last person to
sit on the throne in the Song of Ice and
Fire series but there is something you
must keep in mind regardless of this
interview the show very well may spoil
who is the last person to sit upon the
throne Dan and Dave Mann the show in the
same fashion as George ends his books
George did say they know his ending but
I am surprised that he would confirm the
fate of the Iron Throne this is one of
the many reasons why fans aren't taking
this interview too seriously
but let's move along anyway they also
asked George when it comes to the end of
this series and who will sit on the Iron
Throne some people bet on Jon Snow and
others on Daenerys Targaryen is there
too predictable or not George said in my
novels John is dead and Daenerys has not
even stepped foot on Westeros yet I am
afraid that you have advanced events
that you have not read yet nor do you
know how they will happen there are many
characters and points of view to unravel
everything does not revolve around these
two characters the next question they
ask is so is Jon Snow not the hero of
this story would Daenerys not deserve a
reward after living in exile since
childhood George Martin said I do not
like labels all of my characters have
suffered each in their own way
right from their point of views for a
reason so that we can all understand why
they do what they do and how they feel
in front of the enemy for the Lannisters
the storks are the bad ones it would not
be fair to dismiss them as villains in
their rivals as heroes is John a hero
perhaps but so is Jamie Lannister Sam
Tarly or even Stannis Baratheon each of
them has been a coward once but also
brave if you ask me if John is the hero
of this story I answer that he is not
all are not important as long as they
remain alive among my pages and they
will have the same opportunity to prove
their worth regarding Daenerys I do not
think that deserving in this saga is
synonymous to obtaining in real life
because you are good you do not get
everything that you want I definitely
agree with that last part and I am sure
there are many people who would agree
that John is not a hero and if he were
to be then he is no more a hero than
Jaime Lannister could be seen as I think
the majority of the people see Jon Snow
as a hero like figure but I also know
some people who hate Jon Snow and most
of the decisions that he has made but
that's what I like about this story so
much everyone has their own perspective
on each character and may fault them for
things that some of us may dismiss it's
also very fun and interesting to hear
George's thoughts on his own characters
that he has created but let's move on to
the next question they also asked George
if azor Ahai was a real character in
this series or just a legend could it be
a woman George said as aura high as a
male character in a legend which can be
extrapolated to a female character if
she were to currently exist in Westeros
the gender is neutral from the moment
you decide to point to any of my
characters as such but as aura high is
not any one in particular he forms part
of a fantasy story within a fantasy
series itself any character could be
attributed to a divinity such as the
drowned God or the many-faced God none
of them is a real character they are
mere legends of Westeros see history in
their meaning is symbolic in each part
of the map you can consider as aura hi
to anyone with similar traits the
prophecies must be taken with a grain of
salt and I am amused to see that fans
are
you over the true identity of a
character that is a legend when you have
to know how to read between the lines in
distinguish the fact from the
speculations in my opinion I think you
can't interpret this in many ways but
personally this does sound like
something Jorge would say but if this is
fake it just seems like whoever wrote
this doesn't like when people speculate
about who is or 'hi the reborn character
could be if anyone at all Viktor Alfonzo
asked George if he was satisfied with
the direction of the seventh season of
Game of Thrones since the show is
covering unknown territory in the books
George responded by saying I'm very
happy with the work of the producers it
is a story that will differ from mine in
many ways and I have no complaints they
handle one version and I the other that
also does sound like something George
would say because he's not gonna [ __ ] on
the producers or HBO but honestly I bet
George isn't very happy with some of the
direction they have taken now George
didn't know this what happened but you
can tell from other interviews that it
kind of annoyed him when they would omit
certain characters or plot lines but he
would probably never admit that openly
but behind closed doors I am sure he has
some harsh or criticisms but it is what
it is nothing he can do about that now
there is another part of this Q&A that I
want to read then I will end the video I
do not want to read every single
question and answer in this video
because some of this is a bit lengthy
but the link will be down in the
description if you want to read the
entire thing I do highly recommend
giving it a look if you're interested
that way you can get a better idea of
everything that was said but another
question they asked was there are those
who believe that John could end up with
Daenerys Targaryen as in the series even
Sansa has been proposed as a second
option to be the only noble girl
available do you think it's a crazy idea
in both cases in the very beginning you
had in mind to pair off John with Arya
although I understand the present story
strays very far from that
George responded to this by saying you
have to keep in mind that John in my
books is dead the only thing that I can
assure you is that I never planned on
marrying him off to Sansa because I had
thought in REO when I still didn't have
a very well-formed idea of my story if I
discarded the idea it would be foolish
to think of changing it to meet the
same pattern in the event that John came
back to life at some point the
possibility is very remote I would never
marry him to Sansa they have both been
raised as siblings and neither of them
thinks of the other in a way that goes
beyond brotherly love which doesn't even
exist
aurilla has a better relationship with
John than he does with Sansa and they
won't end up together either to
understand the possible relationship
with Daenerys you'll have to keep
reading the books all right now I would
be very surprised if George did say this
as far as I know George has never
confirmed or even acknowledged his
original outline that was allegedly
leaked online I'm not sure if all of you
have seen it or not but three pages were
leaked online a few years ago and it was
an outline that George may or may not
have rode back in 1993 in that outline
he had written some of the main plot
points he was going to be expanding on
in his books in that outline he also
named five characters that would survive
his entire series and that also showed
that John and Arya were gonna fall in
love with each other but I don't think
George has ever said that was a real
outline if his maybe he did address this
but I haven't seen or heard anything
about that but if this interview is real
then that means that original outline
that you can find online was really his
and although most of it has changed it
could still have some truth to it most
importantly the five characters that he
wanted to live so I don't know if he
would be willing to admit if those were
his true intentions or not unless he
changed everything then it wouldn't
matter but what do you all think about
this interview have you heard anything
about it or have you already read the
entire thing do you think George would
really be this open about some of these
things and many more than I didn't even
mention in this video let me know your
thoughts because I am curious if you
have any added insight on this up until
now I don't think he has confirmed or
denied this interview so it's still up
in the air but in my opinion I just
don't see him answering some of these
questions this way but hey maybe by the
time I upload this video some more
details may have came out that can shed
some more light on this topic but if you
haven't seen the entire interview go
check it out then come back and give me
your thoughts on this thanks for
checking out the video and thank you to
everyone on patreon for your continued
support I really do appreciate that I
hope you all have a great day I will see
you in the next one bye
[Music]